i'd love to pivot yeah i said it um and
ask you guys around robin of questions
you ready
ready i'm ready i'm nervous i'm ready
okay jennifer it's a rainy sunday what
are you doing
baking bread making jam oh
oh god that's so good okay eliza what's
your what is your go-to indulgence these
days
uh
cheese
yes spread it all over i love cheese um
maggie what is your most used emoji
uh the laughing one
with the two tears yes okay jennifer
who is most like their character on
pivoting
the author
as it is autobiographical
abort mission
terrible choices as characters on the
show
i love that because that actually like
if you tell the truth and you tell your
story it's going to be better all right
eliza what is the most embarrassing text
on your phone right now
oh maybe
the last one i just sent to the girls
i'm really just with this storyline for
me and i used to be vegan so this is a
whole thing
i love it i know life without cheese is
a really hard life okay maggie have you
ever ghosted someone
no
oh that's so nice okay jennifer if you
had the power of invisibility what would
be the first thing you would do i think
that i would probably i mean i should
probably be
like seeing what my kids are watching on
television when i'm not in the room oh
my god that's so true
it's so true okay eliza who is the most
surprising person to slide into your
oh dms can't divulge that information
but it's always good
i know it's me
okay but it's someone
it is oh it is someone
maggie uh who was a fun on-screen kiss
i hate on-screen kissing
i know it's so weird we all know this
you guys all know this and i know no
one's going to believe us but like it's
the most uncomfortable
situation to be at no offense man
it's true it's not it's not very um
it's the worst all right well oh okay um
jennifer when's the last time you got
caught in a lie
ah oh the last time i got caught in
hawaii um oh it was recently and it was
somebody gave me a gift and i hadn't
actually opened it and then i was asked
about how i used it and i had to guess
what it was
[Laughter]
i love that eliza what's your favorite
um song right now it's an instrumental
hermanos gutierrez song
oh wow i was not expecting that okay um
maggie has a pickup line ever worked on
you and if so what was it
uh people uh very very rarely hit on me
number one let's get that out of the way
and then number two the ones who do do
the lines i feel like or ever have are
doing it
as a semi joke
because the chance of rejection you see
what i'm saying is very high and so they
put it out there and then there's a
laugh and then it's over yeah yeah i
know i i can't believe no one ever asks
you out maggie i mean if that just if
you don't get asked out good luck for
the rest of
us okay last round jennifer has anyone
ever recognized you and uh you made an
excuse and and then ran away
oh my gosh i used to and you know what i
started feeling like um that is i
started feeling really guilty about
doing that i used to think that i was
like preserving privacy in some way by
like denying who i was and running off
and then i felt like
even someone asking me if i'm me is a
kindness because what they are
expressing in some ways like you are
familiar because i've probably seen
something that you have done and to that
i should be saying thank you and so to
that i now say
yes it is me okay eliza what's one thing
you only do when you're alone
oh
um
yeah i mean take a bath i'm not doing
that with other people
uh maggie ever have you ever used a
bogus excuse to get out of a date and if
so what was it yeah i think i am i think
i once said i would go because i i don't
usually do one-on-one dating that's very
very rare for me it almost never happens
so it's always like a group of people
and i it was like a medical i made a
medical excuse to get out of the dinner
okay first of all i love the group
dating dynamic you're right why aren't
we like what's wrong with that we're
here talking about friendship and
support and parachuting and we're going
on dates by ourselves i think you don't
you think it killed so many birds
without killing any birds because you
sort of i need to know what my friends
think anyway so why wouldn't you just
meet in a group and if immediately
they're like that's not going to work
for us
then you also know and then it's done
and then you don't have to this is the
best screening process ever you guys i'm
not kidding let's go movement
i love this jennifer goodwin eliza coop
maggie q pivoting airs thursdays at 9 30
unboxed
[Applause]
[Music]
you